are you supposed to eat it like this and
this or are you supposed to like I don't
think there are rules I love cheese
giving me all the cheese extra cheese
and everything what is this called a
sugar reward Shakur Sheree
sakru nuri it's very trendy right now
this is what all the cool kids are
eating that's blue cheese it's very
creamy hmm how's like saltiness like
little little grains of salt in it it
was like you loved them too right I like
the kick after it's like an aftertaste
of like it's like herbs Harry Irby
herbaceous cheese bread like a a bit of
a sour aftertaste
does that mean you don't really get to
experience this I'm skilled whenever we
would just stick to crafts single slices
I'm happy I'm cheese like this is often
really just the processed crap I wish I
have better words to describe cheese you
don't like blue cheese no idea I like
all cheese I will literally eat any
cheese just my right here was really
good smell that nope oh wow oh that's
fantastic
although I'm gonna have to pay for this
later give up I'm gonna say all that so
you gotta hate that oh whoa very good it
seems like they're all hiding something
because they're all masked with charcoal
spices imagines are those videos that
they tell you like a secret or something
gross after we eat this what this is not
real cheese dude I mean I'll be shocked
I was happy to be though I actually
really liked that one and I didn't like
to smell it at all you know don't judge
it cheese buy it snow someone put that
on a shirt
so for this one it's one foot up but the
tries through the basically go this is
my jam right here
I love basic cheese it doesn't turn the
cheddar it doesn't have any flavor
smells like peppers in it I like yeah
quesadilla with that shirt I say yeah
I'm a little bit lactose intolerant well
not really be a problem on whoever sits
next to you upstairs
not crazy lactose intolerant you know
it's cheese I've left on the board yeah
mmm-hmm
and then we're like the opposite stuff
maybe the texture of this was good is
like butter this is like sweet it looks
like cheddar cheddar doesn't feel like
cheddar my soul is really upset right
now she's a vegan they're not she I you
can see meaning not coming from animals
wow I'm impressed as I was gonna say I
can never be vegan because I love cheese
so much and I can't survive without
cheese but this I would never guess that
it was vegan cheese if you hadn't have
told me that I wouldn't know that I mean
I wouldn't have thought it that wouldn't
be my first 10 cent that was fantastic
but I'm happy you fooled me I thought it
was just fancy cheese I need the name of
all the cheese's I can bring it to a
party and like shock someone else
[Music]
you
[Music]